The Mirage window smoke arguably the
most iconic smoke in all of Cs go here's
how you throw in CS2 you're gonna come
into this garbage can right here just
like you would on 1286 CS go except
instead of de-strafing into the garbage
can you're just gonna stand still you're
gonna put your Crosshair right here on
this like indentation thing you're going
to crouch you're gonna the nade
back and you're gonna walk forward while
you're crouching and then jump behind
right before your Crosshair reaches this
thing right here so it looks just like
this and that is going to give you a
clean crispy window smoke that lands
every single time the reason this nade
is so overpowered in CS2 is because you
can't extinguish it preemptively with a
Molly doesn't give you one way you see
what would happen in CS go right is that
the teas would throw their window smoke
and the CTs would basically just
preemptively Molly it to create a
one-way where they could see the teas
running out top middle so it's actually
working as intended in CS2 that is the
windows smoke on Mirage make sure you
throw in this game because it's even
better in CSU than it was in CS go